Chris
Peach is
sick that's right I just got the sad
news yesterday evening he's feverish in
fact but he's getting
better not Co another happy thing
however this morning we had a
conversation who's going to teach this
lecture and as you guys know I don't
have to convince you Peach is a very
good
instructor so we said we need one of our
best CA one of our
brightest one of our most
talented one of our most
enthusiastic all of them were busy so
you're stuck with me all
right my name is swin I'm a CA for this
class I teach a couple sections maybe
some of you know me I'm interested in
this material because I really like
thinking about intelligence in the
context of decision making so a lot of
stuff that we deal with in this class
has to do with modeling human
uncertainty making the best decisions we
can with limited information if you ever
want to talk about stuff like that
please let me know but for today we're
going to continue from where we left off
on Friday we saw this really cool result
called the central limit theorem we're
going to talk a little bit more about
that and then we're going to get into
the world of Statistics so let's get
started first things you may have seen
something either talking to your ca or
an announcement
there's going to be a personal challenge
a contest that you can enter if you want
some of the information is going to be
on the course website also on Ed so you
can check there but basically this is
going to be an opportunity for you to
try to take something that you're
interested in and push on it with some
of the tools that you've learned in this
class you'll have a little bit more
control of your grade that way also it's
just a great way to learn I would really
recommend everybody to think about
it so a little
review yeah last time we saw a little
bit more about this business with
convolutions so in
particular whenever we have x equal to0
and y equal to n we know that their sum
is going to be equal to n and if we
consider all these
possibilities we can write out a full
probability like that and that's what a
convolution is for the discret
case we also talked about summing
independent dice roles so first we
looked at the sum of one di roll in this
case we have equal probability across
all six possible values we see something
looking more like a triangle here
and lastly when we have three things
start to look a bit more like a normal
distribution and then we started talking
about what if we have an arbitrary large
sum of these random variables as long as
they're all IID and this is where we got
to the central limit theorem again
really impressive result kind of magical
where as long as we have n independent
and identically distributed random
variables doesn't matter what the
distribution is as long as it's the same
across all of them we're able to if we
know that they're mean Is mu and their
variance is Sigma squ we're able to
write this that the distribution of
their sum is distributed according to a
gaan with its parameters scaled by
n it's not too often that we can say
these very general things without
knowing a lot more about the
distributions we're talking about so
this is a very cool part of the class
and we're going to use some of these
results to do some impressive things
later on in this
lecture also this explains a lot we saw
this phenomenon earlier with this gon
board where if we think about this as n
equals 5 trials in a binomial with
probability .5 each of having a success
either going left or right then we saw
that this starts to look like a normal
distribution well now we can think about
this a bit more precisely if we have a
binomial random variable which is a sum
of bruli IID random
variables then we have this new
explanation here we can say that the
binomial is the sum of brly random
variables and what do we do we're able
to say that the distribution is just
scaling the mean which is p by
n and similarly we take the variance and
scale it by
n and you'll notice that that looks a
lot like the uh normal approximation
that we would use for
binomials so I'd like to play a game i'
like to play a
game the game
involves rolling 10 six-sided dice I of
them
here and we're going to say that you
guys
win in the event that the sum is less
than or equal to 25 or greater than or
equal to
45 and to add some
Stakes I have $24 with
me if you play I'll give you $4 no
matter what and if you win I'll give you
the 20 do I have any volunteers
can I get you yes come on
up okay is it clear what's going on with
the game let's talk about a little bit
more formally each of these di rolles is
going to be one of these X1 through
X10 we're looking at the
sum what's your name oh I think we
worked together at some point earli on
cool these are
yours throw them on the
floor okay I'm looking at a two a three
that's five 9 15 18
19 so we need you to get less than 25 or
sorry less than or equal to 25 total or
greater than or equal to 45 and we're at
19 right
now go for
it that's not good two 6 10 11 13 13 +
anybody know that
one that's
than unfortunately I
wish hey thanks very much for playing
Riley give it a hand for Riley give it
[Applause]
up a thing that you'll learn is uh
especially if you're in my
section I do not play
fair what chance did Riley have of
winning $24 from me let's talk about it
okay using the central limit theorem
we're talking about a sum of 10
Dice and we can know we know we can
write the distribution like this so in
particular we know that mu the average
value of a single di roll is 3.5
calculated this earlier on in the class
similarly for the variance we know it's
352 so what's this normal distribution
that we're going to be able to use we
just scale them both by
10 and so if you run the numbers on the
right hand side or sorry on the left
hand side we're just setting up this uh
this interval that we're looking at
where we consider there to be a win
we're doing one minus the complement of
that on the right hand side we're just
doing the
standardization that way we can plug in
Fes there was only about an 8% chance of
winning this game it was possible but
not probable and that's the kind of
thing we can do with the
CLT okay here's another problem I'm
going to let you guys work on this a
little bit so find one or two other
people around you and just talk through
this
problem
IR
all right let's talk about this we're
hitting 12 traffic lights so these are
excuse me we're hitting 10 traffic
lights these are going to be the random
variables that we're considering now we
know that they're all
distributed the same way
we don't know what that distribution is
but we do know the mean and the standard
deviation can I get a volunteer for
somebody to tell me what a first step is
here I've bribes I've been told I have
bribes I've
Starburst what's up
well like the I traffic light as like
the weight time is Xi the
expectation average weight
time right right so what's your name the
suggestion giving us is we know that the
average weight time across all of these
is going to be 45
seconds that is right there you
go
so if we let T be the total weight time
it's going to be the sum of all these
individual random variables and they all
have have as as was pointed out the same
expectation and then we do something
similar for the variance where we're
going to scale both by this number which
is
10 so we're going to end up using this
distribution and now what's the
event that we're wanting to check for
you'll be on time if your total weight
time is less than 8 minutes can somebody
tell me how we modeled that using this
Rand varable
t
that's exactly right that's exactly
right
okay and so if we plug in
five we get this value here it's
extremely likely that we're going to be
on time in this
case Okay so we've stated the central
limit theorem but a question that you
might have is why should I believe that
the central limit theorem is true
there are going to be times where we
tell you to sort of or at least in this
case I'll be telling you to sort of
trust me a little bit generally not a
great idea but if Chris says you should
trust him then you should do that but in
this case there is a proof there's an
object that we don't use too much in
this class it's called a characteristic
function and if we do some work with
that characteristic function which
involves the size of our sample when we
let that sample go to Infinity we're
going to see that that characteristic
function becomes one of a normal
distribution with the parameters that
you would expect if you want to see more
details about this you can check out
this YouTube video which I believe was
made by a former CS 109
student but for now we'll just take the
CLT at face
value so here it is stated one last
time okay so when we have a sum of IID
random
variables as long as they're IID doesn't
matter what the distribution is exactly
we know that that's going to be in the
limit a normal random variable so here's
a
question what about for the average
average okay so here's the
average of X1 through
xn or we're doing is summing them up
dividing them by n exactly what you
would expect so how would we expect this
to
behave well again by the central limit
theorem as n goes to Infinity we're
actually going to be able to say that
this is normal and you might be able to
tell this based on what we've learned
about linear transformations of normal
random variables but for the sample mean
or excuse me for the mean of the IID
variables instead of it being n * mu and
n * Sigma it's going to be
this and we're going to be using that in
a
moment so here's an interesting
thing I've got
this
sure
cool so let's say this distribution
here is our parent
population and we're going to be drawing
say
five random variables from this
distribution and then here in the blue
section these are the means of these
groups of five that we're talking about
so if I add another one we get more
means still more
means if I add 10,000 pieces from this
overall distribution we see that this
distribution of means starts looking
normal and then if we add even more it
gets more that way now this might make a
lot of sense just because we're already
drawing from a normal distribution but
what if I just make some
crazy crazy distribution like this the
thing we were saying is no matter what
the distribution is as long as it's the
same across the random
variables it should be become normal
when we take the means and so let's look
at
that indeed we see that this happens
just one more example we'll pick a
skewed
distribution and it's centered in a bit
of a different place but we still get an
approximately normal distribution of the
means okay so again the average of the
IID random variables is normal so next
we want to ask about what if we take the
maximum there's a question sorry when
you're saying the
average adding the expectations so when
we're averaging the IID random variables
we just take whatever those variables
end up being so if we have 10 of them
we'll have 10 different numbers kind of
like in the DI roll case we count it up
to 10 actual numbers that we rolled and
then we just took we would take the
average of that to get the
mean welcome yeah why are there how do
you get multiple M then would you just
get one from all the variables and
Sample sorry that one more time why are
there multiple would you just get
one right right so you would just get
one mean per one sample what I was doing
in that function for some of it was I
would take a group of five and just look
at the mean of that and then take
another group of five and look at the
mean of that and that random variable
namely the the means or sorry the mean
that is normally distributed that's what
we were observing let me give you some
starers got one this
way all right so we want to ask the same
question about the maximum of several
IID random VAR oh one more question I'm
just a bit confused about what exactly
becomes normally distributed right um so
is it the sum of all the
DI right it
is the sum is also going to become
normally distributed and that's what we
see in that sum case this is also true
for the average although it's a slightly
different looking normal
distribution so yeah like both of these
lines are referring to two different
things the first one the sum of IID
random variables it does become normal
also the average or the mean becomes
normal as n
grows multiple different trials exactly
and then the averag is going to be that
same thing divided by the number of
Trials
cool so for the maximum of IID random
variables it actually turns out that
just like with the sum and with the
average we get no it's a gumball it's a
gumball I don't make the rules if I did
I wouldn't make them like this we're not
going to have to worry about a gumball
here but the point is there are a lot of
different questions we can ask about
several IID random variables and
functions of them we can take a function
like the sum function like the mean we
can take a function like the Max and
these are distributed in a way that we
can measure measure but in particular
we're focused on the normal one so the
first
two okay got another problem for you
guys we're going to estimate a clock
running
time so we know the mean is or actually
we don't know the mean we're just saying
we're going to represent it by some
value T we do know the variance of the
running time it's going to be Sigma
square equals 4 seconds so what we want
to do is run an algorithm repeatedly and
measure the time of the clock running
for each trial
the question that we want to ask is how
many trials do we need such that
whatever estimate of T that we get is
within this range either 0.5 seconds
below or5 seconds above with 95%
certainty take a second to talk in your
groups again a bit about how this might
work
spe
all right let's pause here any initial
thoughts what are you guys
thinking as first
directions write the mean using the
central limit theorem cool write the
mean using Central limit theorem so we
know that the mean is going to be this
this thing
T and we're going to want to here we're
going to want to say something
about the certainty with which whatever
sample or whatever mean we get for our
runs is close to
that so the way we can represent an
event like this is we want to say with
0.95 probability that's our certainty
estimate that we were going for before
we want to say that the difference
between the mean of the random variables
that we get that's xar minus the true
mean which we're calling T we want that
it's within this
interval and we know that the
distribution of xar minus t follows this
normal distribution why do we know
that because we have that they have the
same standard deviation but we're taking
away the
uh from the sample mean or from the mean
of the random variables we're taking
away the uh true mean and in expectation
those should both be the same so we're
going to have zero as our mean of this
difference and so here we can just use
what we know with the CDF where we take
the upper bound apply the CDF there
subtract off the lower
bound we do our standard our
standardization that we need to for
normal
distributions we end up with
this a little bit more algebra
later and we can solve
directly for
n so using the central limit
theorem we're able to say exactly how
many samples we need to see such that
whatever estimate we get of the mean of
this value T that we were looking at way
back
here is
within 05 of the actual random
variable so that's our exploration of
CLT y x again sure
absolutely so in the top right
corner
there it was said before that like the
expectation
of the mean of IID samples from this uh
distribution namely the one we're
talking about in this problem setup
we're saying that the expectation of
that is going to be T that's what we see
in this line
here
and so if we subtract from this random
variable this constant T it's not going
to change to the it's not going to make
any change to the variance because T is
a
constant but when we look at what the
new expected value is instead of it
being T it'll be T minus t which will be
zero does that help
good
okay so now we're going to move into the
world of statistics let's look at a few
definitions here and we'll do this by
motivating an
example so you guys are into the seventh
week of Cs 109 and so you get reached
out to people by people for help people
like the king of Bhutan now what the
king of Bhutan wants is to get a
measurement of the true mean and the
true variance of happiness in the king
citizens we can't ask everyone though
it's a big enough country to where
that's going to be a bit of an issue so
instead what we have to do is ask 200
people something way less than the total
population now let's be clear if we did
ask everybody then we could just
straight up answer the king's question
we just take the average of what
everybody says for their happiness we
can calculate the variance as well and
then we're good to go but instead we
have a data set that looks something
like this we'll have 200
points and if you want to calculate the
mean of this just this example that we
have here we're going to get something
like
83 so so we could go to the king of bhan
and be like
okay means 83 we're done with the first
part we're going to see that that's a
little bit unfulfilling we're going to
ask is that really a good way to say the
true mean of Happiness among the bud
people so let's look at a population
here we could say this is all of
Bhutan this is our sample of it and so
this is what we're left
with as another example to sort of get
your intuition going for why we wouldn't
want to ask everybody or there are some
cases where it's not even possible
consider you're a a watermelon farmer so
if you're a watermelon farmer you need
to check your watermelon to make sure
that they're not rancid that they taste
good all that kind of thing well if you
check every single one of your
watermelon then you're not going to have
any left to sell so you have to decide
how many you want to test so that you
have a good idea of what your population
looks like without having to sample
every member of it okay so let's talk
about what a sample is is mathematically
speaking it's a collection of these
random
variables so if we had X1 through X200
that could be the random variables
representing people's happiness in
bhuton so this is specifically the
unspecified random variables so we call
this a sample from a distribution if
they're all IID from that
distribution and therefore they're going
to have the
same expectation and
variance so this is a sample of size
eight now a realization of a sample is
when we start getting specific values
when we go ask person one through person
200 and get their actual happiness
scores that's when we get a realization
of the sample of size 200 for the people
who
Bon
okay so let's say we have one sample
this 200 person sample that we were
talking
about so how should we report our
estimated statistics do we just say the
mean is 83 so we're going to report
83 in particular if we wanted to say
something about the error the level of
confidence we have in a region around
some number how we do that and then how
would we later do a thing that we'll
call hypothesis testing that we'll talk
more about on
Wednesday so we don't know the
population mean and the true population
variance if we knew these things we
would just report them back to the king
there wouldn't be a problem the issue is
we don't know what these variables are
or what these parameters are and we want
to have some disciplined way of
estimating them using only 200
samples so we need to think about what
the best estimate would be in the first
place so first let's talk about
estimating the mean so we've got n
random variables X1 through xn they're
all IID they all have the same
distribution they all have the same
expectation specifically
me so how would we estimate this one
intuitive way is just to say okay let's
take the average of those values that's
what we were talking about before that's
how we got that number 83 in our
specific
example but how do we say whether or not
we think this is
good here's one way what if we could say
that the expected value of our
estimate actually matched up with the
true population
mean well we can check this here so
here's the mean of the sample that's
what
is this is just expanding out that
definition over here we're just moving
that factor to the outside the one/ N
since it's a
constant to get to this next line we're
using the linearity of expectations and
we know the expectation of XI for all XI
we were saying they're all the same
across all the variables right so now we
can sub in for the expectation of XI so
now we're summing mu n times dividing it
by n and we get mu on the outside
so this is a powerful statement we're
saying that we would expect this
estimator we're using namely the mean of
the sample that we're
drawing to line up with the true mean of
the
population and we have a term for this
we call this an unbiased estimator now
unbiased means a lot of different things
in different context so try not to
overload this term but as a statistical
term this is exactly what it means when
the
expectation of our statistic lines up
exactly with the true
parameter so even if we can't report the
true parameter because we don't know it
we can say with a reasonable level of
certainty that the 83 we were talking
about before isn't too bad just because
it is
unbiased so we could report something
like
this this is just the sample
mean and then we can also ask about what
the variance of happiness is among the
bo these people so here's the population
variance this should look fairly
familiar from what we looked at variants
before it's just the random variable
minus the mean the square of that
deviation and the expectation of
that population mean there and so if we
only have a sample we're going to do
something kind of similar we might say
something like the average of the
deviations from the sample mean so this
is the sample mean mirroring where the
population mean was before and these big
XI are the instances of our sample
whereas the little XI are just all the
members of the
population so if we take a look here
notice that instead of dividing by n
where n is the number of samples we're
dividing by n minus one and we'll talk
about that a little bit more in a
second so here's a graphic to sort of
tell us what's going on let's say that
this is our full population
here and that the true mean of this
population is Mu right at that
line so what we're doing is we're taking
for each member of the population the
deviation from mu that's what this X1 or
this x IUS mu is we take the square of
that and we're summing that up we do
that for all of the all of the different
data points and so calculation
calculating this Sigma squ
is just doing this precisely for all the
data points so what are we trying to do
instead for the sample mean those
yellowed regions those are going to
represent the samples that we actually
have we can't in the case of puton we
can't talk to everybody about their
happiness level and so instead of the
sample mean or excuse me instead of the
population mean we have a sample mean
xar and it's from this that we're
measuring the
deviations so we're looking at the
difference from X1 to xar and similarly
for the rest of our sampled
points so to get a little bit more
intuition for why we might be dividing
by n minus one instead of just n is that
we need to have a little bit more
variance given that the thing that we're
comparing each of our sampled points to
is also an estimate this xar that we
have here we not we're guaranteed that
it's an unbiased estimate of the true
mean but we don't know that it's going
to be the true mean so you can think of
n minus one in the denominator as
opposed to n as increasing level of
variance that we have over
this now this is another thing
where showing that using n minus one in
the denominator instead of
n knowing that that's an unbiased
estimator is important it's the same
reason why we wanted to use U the mean
before for the unbiased estimate of the
population mean but as you can see the
proof is a bit complicated so this is
something just for reference feel free
to go through it it shouldn't be too out
of range if you wanted take a look but
we know that the expectation of s^2
which is the sample variance when we
Define it
using 1 over n minus one is going to
match with the true
parameter so in that sense we say that
the best estimate of Sigma squ is the
sample
variance okay how do know this is the
unique unbiased
estimator unique unbiased estimator so
if we had something that wasn't or yeah
if we had something that wasn't
um the sample variance over there and we
took the expectation of
it and it matched up with the true
parameter then that would also be
unbiased by the def that we're
using so this need not
be good
question another question what's up um I
don't I think it's pretty circular to
measure accur cacy of your thing by
using the true thing cuz how are you
going to get the true thing if you don't
have the thing gotta got you yeah that
would be circular for sure where is it
that we're using the true thing in order
to make our estimate are you talking
about what this sample mean here yeah
got you so the sample mean is just the
thing we were doing before like with the
dice we were just rolling the dice and
then we looked at the sum there but we
could take the mean there or we had the
specific values that were reported for
those 200 people for bhon so those
aren't actually the true parameters we
are looking at like real samples so
there's some truth there but it's only a
subset of the full population so if we
were using the true population parameter
namely mu over here then yeah we'd be in
trouble because that's exactly what we
don't know that's exactly what we're
trying to calculate so that's a good
thought here you
go
okay so we have our we have a report
that we can give on the average
happiness we have a report we can give
on the
variance and we have our formula for the
sample
variance okay let's do a quick check
let's pair up for this again I'm going
to throw six quantities or sorry six
objects on the board and what I want you
to do within your groups once again is
assign for each of these 1 through six
whether or not it's a random variable or
a collection of random variables or a
value or an event
so go ahead and think about that
together a little
bit
s
all right let's talk about this first
one what do we think is it a random
variable a value or an evance
I hear people saying value that is right
that's exactly right yep mu just stands
for some value okay for two we've got a
sample there random variables value or
event I'm hearing random variables yeah
that's exactly right so each of these X1
through X8 are random variable that can
take on a certain value we don't have uh
we don't have the instantiation of these
random variables yet okay so what's
Sigma Square population variance value
value exactly exactly same reason as for
one and then what is
xar random variable random variable also
correct because we don't know exactly
what it is without getting our
instantiation of the sample like
two now what's five what's going on
there I'm hearing value I'm hearing
event it's going to be event from four
if we're saying that xar is a random
variable then in five we're saying this
is the event that this random variable
namely sample me takes on value 83 and
then lastly what's going on with
six I'm hearing events again yep same
thing as in two we have the random
variables themselves and then we have uh
the instantiations of them so this is
going to be an event perfect okay well
here's something to think about in this
plot that we had here
we're sort of reporting these numbers in
a very exact way we're saying okay
here's our sample mean using an unbiased
estimator it's 83 and then here's an
unbiased estimate of the variance it's
450 but even though the expectations
line up we don't exactly know that we
can be super confident in these numbers
let me give you another example suppose
instead of asking 200 people about their
happiness suppose I ask just one well if
I ask just one
person at least for the the mean let's
say they also they also report 83 then
at least for the mean we're going to
have the same mean in this case and in
the case with 200 people but I think you
guys would agree with me that
intuitively when we're asking 200
different people and aggregating what
they're saying that's something we can
be a bit more confident about that the
mean might actually be 83 as opposed to
well we just happen to find one person
with that happiness
value so let's think a bit about
that so we know that and this is from
the the CLT for for the average of IID
random variables we know
that the mean or the sample mean is
distributed according to this
distribution we don't always know what
these parameters are mu and sigma squ
but we know that they sort of exist out
there and then we've uh we see that yeah
just using the the right side over there
the variance of this random variable is
going to be Sig Square
n so now we can talk a bit about getting
a range that we feel confident about so
in particular we'll start with the
standard error of the
mean so the variance
of our sample mean that's what VAR of
xar is that's a measure of how close xar
is to
Mu so how do we make an estimate of
this so we want to estimate this
parameter on the right hand side now
let's get something very clear here
before when we were doing our un our
unbiased estimate of the variance that
was the variance of like of the sample
excuse me yeah that was that the
variance with respect to like the whole
population now we're just W to ask about
the variance of specifically the sample
mean this random variable that we're
talking about
xar so we want to estimate that thing on
the right hand side and we can do this
using the standard error you can think
of the standard error as yeah an
estimate of the standard deviation of
our estimate of what the mean
is so since we said that s squ which is
the sample variance is an unbiased
estimate of that overall parameter Sigma
squ which is the population variance
well we can accordingly using the
relationship between standard deviation
and variance we can say that the sample
variance Over N is going to be an
unbiased estimate of uh Sigma s n which
is exactly this value that we're wanting
to
estimate and it'll come through
accordingly so here's this worked out a
little bit more
this is the substitution we're making
where we're saying that the sample
variance is an unbiased estimator of
Sigma squ so this uh this equality sign
here is a little bit misleading but
we're sort of making the substitution
for the sake of getting an estimate
because we don't know this true
parameter and so then we get the
standard error of xar just like that
taking the square root of our
estimate and so these are the numbers
that we get for the B
poll in particular this will come out to
about
1.5 so what does this mean we now have
some measure of the spread of the
estimate that we're giving so we're not
just saying
83 instead we can
say we're thinking 83 and we're going to
give a range of about two we're being a
little conservative here we're extending
a bit outside of the 1.5 that we
calculated and saying we're reasonably
sure that it's going to be within a
little bit more than one standard
deviation and so we get a more precise
statement than just saying like Okay 83
is the mean that we got y
stand so let's take a look
at uh let's go back a little bit
more so when we have s s here interpret
that similarly to how we looking at
Sigma
squ
where it's more of a notational thing if
we take the square root of it we can
call it s but what that means
is uh just taking the square root of
that
overall that overall function here so we
could write this as like s overun of n
if we wanted to but it's just a matter
of notation those should both be the
same thing does that make sense cool let
me give you some Starburst
okay so now let's think about how we do
this for the
variance what we've been able to say is
we've been able to report three things
now even though we were only asked for
two we were asked to be we're asked to
give the true population mean and the
true population variance obviously we
can't get those exactly otherwise we'd
have to sample everybody so instead what
we said is here's our sample
mean and also here's a region over which
we we can be kind of confident that it's
correct and so we're trying to do
something similar for
variance this is a trickier thing and
we're going to see more about this on
Wednesday but for now let's take a look
at another example of
this so here are some of the pet
timings for the questions that you guys
have worked
on so we have a list for the amount of
seconds that it takes each
person at least as they're writing out
the answers for each problem on the P
set
so let's take a look at some code
here we've got a function analyze and
what we're wanting to do is something
similar that we did for the people of
bhuton except with respect to the pet
timings so we can start this first line
is just doing some cleaning here when
we're what we're taking in is the
question key and then the list of times
and so we're just going to remove out
all of the extraneous you know all of
the unclean parts so all of the parts
that have zeros which doesn't really
make any sense so we're left with a more
accurate list we can take the length of
that list and now we can just in code do
the kinds of things that we've been
doing in the last few slides so first we
can look at the sample mean which the
unbiased estimator we were using was
just taking the mean over the sum of all
the items in the sample that's exactly
what's going on here with np. mean and
to be clear NP is the shorthand we're
using for
numpy next we can get the sample
variance and the only weird thing here
is going to be this DDF now this is a
parameter for degrees of freedom and
setting this equal to one is how we get
the minus one in this denominator it's
just a thing to remember if we set this
to zero then that's going to give us the
case where we have 1/n which is not or
is not an unbiased estimator it is a
biased
estimator okay here we're getting the
standard error which we got just using
the formula that we had before we had
the sample variance divid by n square
root of
that and then if we want the sample
standard deviation that's just taking
the square root of the sample
variance and so now we have all of these
items and if we want to Output their
values we can do it like this for each
question we have the mean number of
seconds that we were looking at for
somebody to solve it we have this plus
minus in that first row it's the
83.8 that's giving us a range around
which we can be pretty comtable on our
estimate of the mean that's our standard
error on the right hand side we have the
standard deviation of time with respect
to all of the samples that we're looking
at not just the
mean and we have this for all the
questions and so we can plot that
here so we have this for each question
the a bars are exactly what we were
looking at in the uh in the bhuton case
and if we want to look at what's the
expected amount of time for future that
somebody would spend on a problem set
well we can just take the expectation of
the sum being the sum of the
expectations for each problem and what
we have on the right hand side is it
looks like about 2.87 hours for Pet 1
pet 3 looks more like 5.11 hours so if
you're budgeting say 50 hours for pets
it looks like in this case we'd be
pretty happily coming in under
time and these are two questions that we
were a bit surprised to see if we have
access to all the data why are we
estimated sure
right so what we don't have is some true
population over all students
say so we could we could get population
statistics for like everybody that's in
this database but if we want to say
something more General about like a
population of students more broadly then
this is an estimate of
that
okay so looking back at the Baton case
we're w to get the standard deviation
there or sorry the standard error there
and we did that but we still have a
question mark about getting some kind of
standard error about the sample variance
there's a
question can you always use the sample
mean as an unbiased estimator for the
mean or are there some cases where it's
like if if you say like chose your
sample really poorly like for example in
here like if you only um measured the
happiness of like like
parents in bhan and not U children or
like in the cs1 or9 case like if you if
there was some like correlation between
students who hads then you just assume
that your true mean was your was your
sample mean even though it's not right
this is a great point and and I'll try
to I'll try to repeat what you were
saying uh paraphrased a little bit it's
like what if we're not doing a great job
of sampling like what if there's some
significant dependencies between like
we're getting some subset of the
population that's all actually very
similar to each other I'm sure you guys
have run across things like you know
respond responders bias or something
where like if you just sort of send a
pull out to people you might not get a
representative sample of the people that
are most likely to respond things like
that so for this question this is
absolutely a good concern to have the
way that we get past it in terms of
writing things out in terms of what is
and isn't an unbiased estimator has to
do with that initial assumption we were
making about our sample which is that
each data point that we're looking at is
IID from the overall
distribution so if they're all
identically distributed and independent
from each other that's the kind of
assumption and it is an assumption that
we should check as we're doing data
collection this is a an empirical
problem that you guys will run into if
you want to work in this area but in
order to make that assumption or Sorry
by making that assumption we Shield
ourselves from worries like oh there's
actually a lot of pretty strong
dependencies between the people that
we're getting samples from and things
along those
lines all right this is going to be end
ious that was pretty good right yeah
okay so if we want to start getting some
estimate on the error that we have for
our sample variance we're going to need
to go into bootstrapping and we can talk
about that more on Wednesday but for now
let's talk a bit about the midterm that
we had last
week
so here's the distribution that we ended
up getting got some colors here to sort
of bracket things in the groups just
going along the xaxis increments of Five
Points so to make things maybe a little
bit more concrete this green region that
we're looking at we're thinking like
that's a B plus a minus kind of thing
the blue is going to be like a minus a
the purple is going to be a A+ and then
we'll say that the yellow region is like
around a b and so this is the this is
the performance that we had as a
class
uh you can our statistics there for the
mean and the
variance if you want to go through the
lecture slides and take a look at these
correlations Between You Know How likely
people are to do well on certain
problems in relation to others and then
we can just talk about a few things for
the logistics here so again take a look
at that information on the contest and
beyond that we'll see you on
Wednesday